welcome back the washington post under
fire once again for its obvious bias
against president trump and his
supporters
the paper publishing a cartoon and
insulting cartoon
depicting republican congressmen and
state attorneys general
as rats for their support of trump's
legal challenges
uh to the presidential election
particularly in the uh in the high court
but you know jesse uh i wouldn't call
them rats i think rats is offensive it's
insulting it's a partisan
a partisan knife jab but i would call
them lemmings another kind of rodent
creature
where the they follow the leader no
matter what and it jumps off a cliff and
they all go running off the cliff and
the
they all get crushed in the canyon floor
uh you know i i
as a lawyer looked at the challenges to
the presidential election
and i could not believe frankly that the
state attorneys general were all signing
on
uh you know it was such a hail mary
to begin with had such limited chance of
success jessie
i don't think they're lemmings they're
just doing what their constituents
believe
and all politicians support their
president for the most part
i just see this as politics nothing
wrong with that geraldo
what i don't like about the cartoon is
it's kind of like the rat
blacklist do you remember after the
election where aoc had this idea the
trump accountability project
where she they were going to name names
of all these trump supporting
republicans
and they were going to isolated
intimidate and shame them so they could
never work again
that's this kind of continuation of that
because it wasn't just
anonymous rats they put their names on
there so there was a message there
the other thing is the hypocrisy when
donald trump
said that baltimore cummings's district
was rat
infested because remember he was saying
he didn't like the conditions down at
the border
there was a weak coverage of that and i
have
i have the receipts here we have the new
york times said
infestations justify exterminations
they compared likening insects to vermin
and genocide
they called it like nazi ideology and he
was just speaking
as a guy in commercial real estate not
not making any sort of
equation between nazi extermination and
black people
so i don't think this column this did
that although it does have a similarity
between the propaganda in the in the
third reich with those
cartoons i didn't think she meant that
but she didn't give
and they didn't give the benefit of the
doubt to donald trump
when he used the exact same word
well that's it seems to me that's all
word smithing though dana that's
what i do uh this one use this that's
what you do
and indeed but you know what bothers me
about this uh
this mindset among the state attorneys
general i know i'm going a little
uh off on the tangent here but the
mindset is
advocating and some have specifically
advocated
including the uh colonel alan west the
head of the gop in texas
uh and uh the the woman who heads the
arizona gop
they're advocating secession they're
advocating a union
within the union or without the union
it's almost like they want a civil war
it's getting very
stressful for me personally uh to watch
this uh this kind of jingoistic rhetoric
and they have
you know uh sydney powell was in the
white house stressing her all the way
out we better stop
we don't want to stress geraldo out
because these words are upsetting that's
right haralda's been in war zones but
they're like
quiet you bullies now dana what do you
think i think
in some ways you know she she lists
everybody here that signed on to it like
members of congress and everyone
and you know in some ways i i i think in
some ways they knew that the supreme
court would reject it so
they knew their constituents wanted them
to do it so they felt like they could do
it maybe some of them believe it
look we've got some work to do in this
country to repair and to move forward
together the one thing i would say about
this attempt by the
columnist who obviously would prefer
democrats to be in office
is that this kind of thing is
counterproductive it is not working
i want to underscore for people just how
much this idea of cancel culture
and elitism against republicans hurt
democrats
down in the down ballot races all across
the board just look at nancy pelosi
losing all of those seats
it really did make a difference and down
there in georgia right now you have um
ossoff saying he never wanted
republicans to show their faces again
you have warnock calling on republicans
to repent
for supporting trump and that stuff
registers with the voters
and i think that's why you see that
those two candidates are starting to
like fall behind
the republican challengers because this
whole idea of cancel culture
it doesn't work on either from either
perspective but the democrats are
certainly trying
and a column like this or a cartoon like
this does i agree that it was a
i agree there was a political play by
the attorneys general
but you don't mess around when you're
messing with the republic the fabric of
the very fabric of the republican katie
i think that this diminishes diminishes
president trump's
legacy when you keep tearing at the uh
you know fighting this uh
this war with the you know with the
lawyers meeting in the war rooms and
general flynn
and they're talking about calling out
the that means some crazy stuff that uh
it sounds like a bill more monologue
katie
well geraldo you are accusing colonel
allen west and kelly ward who is the gop
chairwoman in arizona
wanting a civil war but i want to get
back to what this cartoon
implies in terms of that kind of
violence and behavior against someone
that you are politically opposed to
she drew a bunch of rats and wrote the
names of republicans next to them she's
dehumanizing them by
comparing them to rodents and what do
you have to do with rodents geraldo you
have to get rid of them
you have to exterminate them you kill
them so if we want to talk about people
implying violence against the other
side cartoons like this are certainly
doing that
um with that kind of messaging by
comparing people who
just a couple of minutes ago they were
saying they wanted to unite with and
everyone needed to come
around you know for the sake of the
country and for the republic
this kind of behavior is exactly the
opposite and sends the message that
republicans really aren't humans and
therefore you can just get rid of them
whatever that means it just seems it
seems to me greg that both sides are
guilty of this now
what a weasel thing to say why does that
weasel
because you are you are purposely
avoiding are you saying purposely
so the republicans are innocent you
completely
you completely avoided the the essential
truth
of this story that we've officially
completed the circle of hate
the same people who smeared trump
supporters as nazis
now compared trump supporters to rats
which is what the nazis did to the jews
okay so the people
appear to call you a nazi are only
projecting
so they can they can utilize their nazi
mannerisms
against them that's the circle of hate
and this is a lesson
that even in victory they will hate you
so if people thought that the trump 2016
win
was behind the vitriol for four years no
it merely highlighted what was
already there which is as as katie said
rats are a way to dehumanize you
for the purpose so future
suggestions so you can rattle on about
suggestions
you are suggesting that denying the
results of the election is not adding to
the vitriol
it's not adding to the hatred it's not
adding to the division
so you're saying that excuses that
excuses
into his son